Learning management systems are tools or
collections of tools that are meant to
help teachers and educators with
the administration of their classrooms.
They take a lot of things that
traditionally we may have done in
person or done by hand and
put them online or
put them on a computer in
order to make things easier or
to help with distrivuted classrooms
like the one's here in the LMS program.
They might have things like
a grade book or a facility for
collecting assignments or
a workflow for grading assignments.
By now, you're very familiar with one
particular learning management system,
which is T-Square.
You've seen T-Square's assignment
system, its announcement system,
its resources system,
its testing quizzes system, maybe.
Those are all different tools that are
collected together under one management
system in order to try and deliver
a cohesive classroom environment.
Even though we use a lot of tools here,
the ultimate goal of learning
management systems is to put
a lot of things together.
Of course, one difficulty with
learning management systems is it's
easy to approach them from
a purely system perspective.
It's easy to look at them as software
solutions to a software problem.
But that actually can be
a little bit dangerous.
To design good learning
management systems,
we need to have some understanding
of the learning process as well.
We need to have some understanding
of the pedagogy behind
learning management systems.
We need to have some understanding of
the learning behaviors in which students
will engage while they're
using our systems.
So that's what we'll
talk a lot about here.
Not only what a learning management
system needs to be able to do, but
how to design it in such a way that it
actually helps the learning process.